c'est andré 2e prix mme andréa ouais
d'accord agile ou andré vous montrant
vous êtes c'est mal parti en fait j'ai
assez bien
gilles c'est ben ouais non un succès
aino et dans bruxelles mais on part tôt
mais sur la france intra muros non dans
les pays de l'est hé ben ali mais son
prénom alors je viens d'apprendre
j'ai envie que j'aurais pu faire un truc
aujourd'hui vous poser une question oui
bien sûr je veux ma maman m'a fait la
réflexion et je n'avais pas fait
attention
bah écoutez vous appelez tous les
chroniqueurs par leur prénom et mets pas
mon nom de famille oui mais pour quelle
raison cher ami parce que valérie ça ne
va pas mais c'est vrai vous gala vous
comment alors comment vous souhaiteriez
me prénommé alors vous franchement oui
régine
[Applaudissements]
prénom c'est quoi ton nom et un prénom
wali maxime ah oui quand-même joue le
même délire coire écoute j'ai une
famille qui est française une famille
qui essaie mais ils avaient prévu un
prénom au cas où ça tourne mal tout ça
caroline ithurbide arts vous vous avez 1
vous n'avez pas une tête à vous appeler
caroline avon et dans les tests et mon
prénom et monde depuis deux jours
d'accord je m'appelais toujours je
m'inventais des prévenus quand j'étais
en vacances pour une italienne appelée
victoria tout le monde tous les vacances
tous les mecs que je rencontrais et
ouchy s'est jamais montré nez et encore
moins aux mecs surtout un haut surtout
d'accord et c'est pas votre deuxième
prénom alors c'était pas gagné ces
jeunes viennent et victorine 14 c'est un
prénom qui ne s'invente pas pour moi
c'est quoi aimer aimer ou un régime et à
aimer le bachelor c'est vrai mais c'est
une tradition familiale on donne le nom
de l'oncle désaccord et londres a donc
votre oncle s'appelait mais aimer away
et 91 jacquet
maxime comme deuxième prénom c'est
philippe on dirait qui a mis sur la
table mais on dirait qu'il va nous
sortie aux gens mohamed au deuxième
prénom c'est joe mohamed les toubous de
m'appelle jean momo valérie vidal ou
quelle case canal+ a proposé à michel
drucker pour la rentrée prochaine base
et régine régime oui et donc c'est quand
même assez andré deuxième prénom andrea
ouais d'accord est agile ou andré vous
montrez vous étiez mal parti en fait
l'annoncé à ses biens jl-c d'arbres dans
le succès à une norme sociale mais on
part tôt mais sur la france intra muros
non dans les pays de l'est à paris lors
d'un sermon castaldi alors quel est
votre deuxième prénom c'est ses anges au
jeu mais comme mon père mon grand père
non c'est quand mon père est cadre
innovant fait un éloge à moi je trouve
que ça fait beaucoup si je peux mourir
mon père il a beaucoup pêcheront ça
plonge son prénom
maintenant il chope et c'est injuste au
téléphone et je m'appelle anges les mof
qui fait l'eau avait toujours quoi anges
un troisième prénom yves yves à wallace
assez appréciable
[Musique]